hello everyone my name is bradley and
this is some sub your detailed guide on
how to survive in the online jungle now
in many of my videos i've talked
repeatedly about how fraudsters steal
your bank details with the help of
phishing sites clever skimmers or simple
telephone conversations but today we're
going to talk about instances of when
criminals use their own cards to commit
fraud now similar to the military term
friendly fire this type of crime is
called friendly fraud but there's really
nothing friendly about it at all
i mean in a friendly fight situation
soldiers mistakenly kill their own
allies friendly fraud means that
ordinary buyers become criminals
sometimes intentionally but sometimes
because they're not even aware of what
they're really doing
so you sure that your bank does not
suspect you with fraud
[Music]
but before we talk about this kind of
fraud itself let's tackle one important
concept
chargeback
now this is the name of the procedure
for cancelling an already made payment
for let's say a product or service with
the mass introduction of credit cards
the need for chargeback became quite
apparent
hey world who do you take traveling
mastercard and me now when paying in
cash the buyer can usually immediately
evaluate what he or she was buying if
the quality of the goods was in doubt
you could just immediately cancel the
transaction you return the purchase and
well get your money back
so in the case of using debit or credit
cards everything's much more complicated
because of the intermediary between you
and the bank or the seller right and
silicon immediately return the funds to
you even if they agree with the claim
additionally there's the risk of say
erroneous transactions for instance the
double debiting of funds
so this is ultimately why cashless
payments were always less attractive
than
the use of good old cash right and
therefore in 1974 american banks lobbied
for the fair credit billing act
now according to this new law a
dissatisfied buyer could contact his
bank and demand the cancellation of some
payment the bank would study the
circumstances surrounding the
transaction conduct its own
investigation due diligence and either
return the money to the client or give a
reasoned refusal therefore in pursuit of
a good reputation banks increasingly
began to side with the customers now of
course very quickly there were people
who noticed the vulnerabilities in the
system the very possibility of being
able to buy something and then have the
money returned became a reason for the
appearance of charge back fraud in the
first place so as we're explaining to
this friendly fraud
so let's take a look at some chargeback
statistics and try to separate the
honest customers from the scammers
according to expert market almost 30 of
such requests are related to stolen
cards now here the things are pretty
straightforward among such appeals
you're unlikely to find many instances
of friendly scammers with a card stolen
from your pocket it's not that simple to
withdraw cash right
of course attackers can always try to
catch sight of your pin code in advance
but this is really no easy task besides
then the criminals will have to be
standing next to you and therefore if
the card is immediately used to withdraw
cash at say the nearest atm then the
bank security service will definitely
have some questions for you and perhaps
they could even analyze his tv of say
who was standing next to you in those
instances and therefore withdrawing
money from your card and then reporting
it as stolen is a one-way ticket to jail
without passing go
a more attractive option is the
possibility of withdrawing funds in a
series of small payments that do not
require additional authorization however
such unusual activity will surely
attract the attention of your bank
security programs and payments will be
blocked so you won't have anything to
dispute there so this is also an
unsuitable option for friendly scammers
some problems will also arise if you
first go on say an online shopping spree
and then report that your card has been
stolen namely the delivery address will
give the game away ordinary scammers
might use fake recipients but this only
makes sense when you've got a constant
stream of criminal purchases if you have
a database of the card details of 700
people then the idea will pay off but if
you have your own credit cards which
regularly go missing this will only
raise questions i suppose from the bank
security service
so among the numerous applications for
card theft we're unlikely to find a
significant number of friendly scammers
here it's worth looking for traces of
carders social engineering specialists
or phishing that is those who actually
steal card data and use it without your
knowledge
the second most popular reason for
requesting chargebacks is the lack of
goods or services
this is simple let's say you've made an
advanced payment but you haven't
received anything in return
in fact there can be many reasons for
this from the mistake of the manager who
let's say incorrectly processed your
order to actual problems with the
logistics company and it's pretty easy
to prove that you haven't had your house
renovated or received the lawn mower you
ordered so you just make an application
to the bank for a refund
in order for the payment to remain in
force well your opponent will have to
prove that he or she has fulfilled their
obligations for example they'll provide
let's say a receipt of prepares or proof
of postage with a shipping company and
if they fail to prove their case the
money will return to you this provides
some opportunities for friendly scammers
but there aren't many here in the modern
world it's almost impossible to actually
deliver goods or do some work without
leaving any trace and therefore in order
to find the heroes of today's video we
need to dig a little bit deeper now in
third place among the reasons for
chargebacks comes the unsatisfactory
quality of a product or service 15 of
all chargeback claims are due to this so
let's take a closer look at some of
these statements
at least once we've all bought something
that was a little well dissatisfactory
when it arrived in the post let's say
disappointing right
and wish i'm looking at you
but anyway it's worth noting that in
this case you have received the order
and it's probably documented too but now
you just don't want to pay for it
now let's say the size of the jacket you
bought wasn't quite right we didn't like
the color of that hair dye well it would
be logical to try and solve this problem
directly with seller right but now only
one out of every 20 people actually does
this the remaining 19 will they open
dispute at the bank and demand a refund
from them
but why well firstly it's much easier
this way there's no need to deal with
applications and refund forms for each
specific seller there's just one
universal form that you fill out at your
bank and it's suitable for returning
money for both a baseball cap and for a
car and according to statistics 40 of
those who applied for a refund will do
it again within two months
and secondly it's a lot faster most
often even before a detailed examination
of the application has been carried out
the money is already returned to the
buyer's account
now automatically the seller has to
undergo a long dispute process right and
besides almost half of the customers
don't actually fully understand how the
chargeback mechanism itself works they
just want to get their money back as
soon as possible from a formal point of
view such requests for chargebacks are
not entirely legal
now cardholders don't really think about
whether their reasons for claiming a
chargeback are actually valid you need
to remember that in a lot of statements
customers they're not completely honest
about the reasons for their refund and
this is actually classified as perjury
thirdly often in disputed cases the
goods cannot actually be returned with a
well-presented claim the seller doesn't
actually have a great chance of proving
his case at all if the seller is also
found guilty he is forced to pay all of
the costs associated with the
investigation the bank fees and also the
fines and if claims arise regularly well
the bank may actually refuse to work
with a company altogether only very
large stores can afford to organize the
return of rejected goods ensure they're
repackaging and sale
amazon and everybody else is constantly
trying to you know enhance that user
experience and figure out how do you
best do that
but you still have the reverse shipping
you have to pay for that shipping to go
back
you have to deal with the item itself
how do you file it away how do you deal
with it and it's much easier for small
producers to just write off such goods
immediately this is actually what
friendly scammers can tap into their
activities actually only differ from
shoplifters and the fact that they don't
actually have to leave the house to
steal goods and they're not really
worried about the fact that the seller
will lose much more than the amount
stayed on the receipt you need to
remember that on average for every
dollar of goods appropriated by
fraudsters well that results in a loss
of 2.5 dollars for the seller
but maybe you're not really impressed by
these figures so i'll put it in
different terms in 2020 experts
estimated the volume of activity of
friendly scammers at 4.8 billion dollars
which means that the seller's losses
amounted to more than 10 billion
additionally in recent years a new
reason for requesting refunds has
emerged an accidental subscription to
interactive services now i'm sure you've
seen these ads for online streaming
services that maybe offer the first
month for like a discounted price or
even free right but then after the
advertising period the subscription fee
will come into play or maybe it will be
15 to 20 times the original charge this
sort of price is unlikely to appeal to
the person who is used to receiving a
fully fledged service almost for free
moreover we rarely read all of the terms
and conditions you would be well
it would take a huge amount of time
right
the norwegian consumer council has
actually calculated they'll tick you in
about an hour to read all of the rules
for using facebook almost two hours for
linkedin and itunes as terms of use will
take more than three hours to read
who has that time
and particularly vulnerable to such
things are our children now a couple of
years ago amazon's finances agreed to
return more than 70 million dollars to
its users why well young children made
purchases for this amount and they used
their parents devices and made small
purchases all without their consent now
as a rule such transactions are quite
small but in total on average more than
100 can be spent actually by each child
over the course of some time none of the
transactions were contested because the
real cardholders didn't actually give
their informed consent to purchases on
amazon in these cases the children
didn't try to deceive the internet
company but they deceived their parents
by spending the money without their
permission
but perhaps this is the most difficult
type of friendly fraud to calculate the
only thing really that comes to mind is
the creation of individual user profiles
which will track the behavior and
interests of each person in the system
if i don't know you've got a
subscription to say the wall street
journal
and you know this is the only thing you
pay for and then suddenly you know you
spend about a hundred dollars playing
candy crush it doesn't quite add up
right but if you're into those online
games you know then it's a different
story now without waiting for favors
from online stores and banks there is
actually something parents can do to
take financial security of their
families now feel free to use parental
controls on your kids phones for a start
get a separate physical or virtual bank
cards also pay for subscriptions for
online services and games and also check
the statements on this card regularly
it'll help you notice in time that your
hard-earned dollars are slowly being
turned into roebucks
according to makata advisory group
losses from friendly fraud in 2020
exceeded 50 billion dollars and on
average this figure increases by 20
every single year i wouldn't be
surprised if in a few years we forget
about all these old methods and we'll
actually be carefully studying and
classifying new types of friendly
scammers i mean this stuff is changing
all the time but anyway i don't think
this is the last time that cyber
criminals are going to be surprising me
but who is me i am bradley and i do
solemnly swear that i am not a
chargeback fraudster
the big question is are you
in any case chargeback fraudster or not
i will see you lovely people in our next
video thanks for joining us
[Music]